[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rose I'm the
executive director here at the long now
foundation as some of you know we start
these talks with what we call a long
short a short film that exemplifies long
term thinking Andrew from our staff
found this one for tonight's talk which
I think was amazingly appropriate and I
think one of the interesting stories
with it is symbology symbology is one of
those things that not only can it be
powerful but you can actually forget how
permissive it can be and this is a great
story of once you change the symbol does
the does the story still hold enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from long
now we tend to think about things in
terms of anecdote anecdotes which we
interpret is good news or bad news in
relation to some narrative that we take
seriously long-term thinking tries to
step away from or look up from or back
away from anecdote and look at long-term
trends which may or may not relate to
narratives they just happen and so the
rate of population growth for humans was
trending upward for quite a while and
then in 1976 it deflected and started
trending downward and still trending
downward a couple years ago Steven
Pinker gave a talk here in the series on
the decline of violence which has been a
secular trend for millennia and
centuries and years and practically down
to the month level our speaker tonight
is is building in a sense on Pinker's
work which was called the better angels
of our nature
and looking at some of the dynamics and
mechanics in how it actually works
the trends of morality over the very
long term Michael Shermer
thank you so much Stuart thank you I
really appreciate you all coming and
it's a great honor to be here thinking
long-term is really what it's all about
I was telling Stuart earlier that I
thought it'd be funny if he was
chronically frozen and came back in a
thousand years and on the 10,000 year
clock there was a watering can on top of
the thing and it became a religion I
mean that's kind of how it happens it's
it's not it's not completely crazy but
yes that's right we we should follow the
trend lines not the headlines if you
just pay attention to the headlines of
course it seems like things are bad and
getting worse but if you follow the
trend lines and that is not the case
it's hard not to watch the news and see
Syria and civil wars and and places like
Ferguson and police shootings things
like this it just seems like things are
bad but it's important to kind of put it
in perspective which I want to try to do
tonight I was thinking about this on
Sunday I spoke at a place called Sunday
assembly ironically it was on Sunday and
and so as a tribute to the they had some
live music they had a live band so as a
tribute for the book they played The
Beatles song it's getting better all the
time and I kind of remember the song
it's sort of a happy positive song but
they had the lyrics up on the screen and
they got to the lyrics where he says you
know something about I've been treating
my woman bad I've been beating her and
keeping her from the things she loves I
thought host Sir Paul beating your woman
I mean you wouldn't write those lyrics
today I mean that's that's the sort of
thing that has was once you know just
sort of a toss off line it rhymes I beat
my woman arrives okay it's it's a little
bit like Jackie Gleason's character in
the honeymooners you know Ralph Kramden
was going to hit his wife so hard sent
her to the moon well you can't say that
kind of thing anymore that those are the
sort of little pop-culture examples of
long-term trends that that the shift
happens slowly enough you don't really
notice it then all of a sudden when you
hear it it's jolting beat my woman Wow
so that's the idea behind the arc of
course the inspiration is the great dr.
Martin Luther
Jr at the climax of his march from Selma
and Montgomery as featured in the film
where he gave the second most famous
speech he ever gave called how long not
long which you can watch on YouTube
unfortunately that's the only place
you'll see it because it's not in the
film they couldn't get the rights to the
to the speech so they made up a speech
and he gave a different speech in the
film which is unfortunate because it is
great and he got that theme from a 19th
century Unitarian preacher named
Theodore Parker who talked about the arc
of the moral universe bending toward
justice in 1853 seven seven eight years
before the Civil War so that's some real
optimism there so King gave this speech
in March of 1965 and that summer in
August the Voting Rights Act was passed
so that's some fairly rapid progress you
can see dr. King they're looking
overlooking the shoulders their abductor
of President Johnson signing into law
and so the first chart I'll show of many
tonight from the book tracks the the
number of the growth of democracies not
just any democracies these are
democracies that have scored eight or
higher on the polity project the polity
project rates democracies on a one to
ten scale so you have to score eight or
higher to get on this graph which and
they base it based on things like how
transparent the elections are how fair
they are does everybody have the
franchise to what extent does money
influence an election you can imagine
such a thing you can see the little dip
after the during during the fur in the
Second World War and then the spiked up
and then a huge spike in the 1980s and
918 democracies in the world now out of
the 196 countries so a predictable a
hypothesis that I would predict then
would be this should continue growing if
it doesn't then I could be wrong in this
particular area and so part of the
liberal democracy is that everybody gets
the right to vote including blacks and
women didn't happen here in the United
States until 1920 this was one of the
great suffragettes who's one of the
heroes of my book her name is Ynez mill
Holland and she led a march on
Washington DC on that white stallion can
you imagine following her can you
imagine being with the cops
to stand in front of her and go you
can't go never mind so here's how it
happened again a little burst after the
first world war 19 you know United
Kingdom in the United States and then
and then another burst after the Second
World War interestingly you'll see that
the first countries to grant women the
right to vote were all islands
the first was Pitcairn Island in 1836
remember Pitcairn Island where the
Bounty mutineers ended up you know I
think there was 13 of them total and
eight were women and that was it they
got the vote every country except Saudi
Arabia which is supposedly I just put a
question mark in the book cause you know
we'll see supposedly they're gonna do
this in 2015 we'll see when I was
researching I thought it was amusing
that the Vatican City said never of
course they don't have any women so
that's part of the problem and I don't
just mean for voting rights anyway
that's another subject and we're in the
midst of another rights revolution right
now gay rights and same-sex marriage the
beauty of this particular one is we can
watch it unfold in real time week by
week month by month and and you can see
who supports it and who opposes it
the transition came in 2011 when more
people were in favor of it than we're
against it you can see the shift in our
own president who in 2008 said I believe
marriage is between a man and a woman
I'm not in favor of gay marriage and
then in 2012 he said I've concluded for
me personally it's important to go ahead
and affirm that same-sex couples should
be able to get married now to be fair
you never know what politicians really
mean because he said the oh wait one
when he was campaigning and he said the
2012 one after he'd won the election so
but anyway whatever it takes to get us
there that's the process you can see who
tends to support it and oppose it so if
one factor is age the younger you are
the more likely you are to support a
rights revolution of any kind in this
particular one the Millennials people
born in 1981 or after our most
supportive of same-sex marriage
followed by Generation X and us baby
boomers sort of pulling up the rear
there and lagging way behind or the
Silent Generation but not to worry they
won't be with us that much longer
no sorry no I I'm just joking ages is
definitely a factor though it's a
predictive variable in terms of openness
to experience and change and and and
that sort of thing as you can see who
opposes it we can we can watch the
speechifying by politicians and
political pundits and in in opinion
makers the white evangelical Protestants
are the least in favor of it then black
Protestants white mainline Protestants
Catholics and most in support of it are
the nuns the religiously unaffiliated
nuns and Oh n es nut and u Anna's people
that tick the box for no religious
affiliation are the most supportive of
this particular rights role but that's
always the case so this is one of the
theses of my book is that secular forces
have been driving moral progress the
most over the last several centuries
even dr. King who was obviously a
Baptist minister but in his own
autobiography he said his strongest
influences were Gandhi and the most
liberal theologians that he had read
when he was in training by the way I
have good news for you who were in favor
of not only gay marriage but also pot
legalization I think this might be not
not too controversial here in San
Francisco that is if you still feel like
your friends need theological support
and so on I found some biblical support
for both gay marriage and pot
legalization because in Leviticus
chapter 20 verse 13 it says if a man
lies with another man he must be stoned
[Applause]
so you can quote that to your religious
friends and go on Bill O'Reilly and
anyway that's a so let's look just a few
of the positive things that have
happened over the long-term trend lines
the abolition of slavery happened very
rapidly in the late 18th and early 19th
century primarily driven by secular
forces the invention of Rights or if you
will the discovery of rights the idea
that humans have natural rights that you
get by virtue of being human and that
they should extend to more and more
people the expansion of the moral sphere
to include more members of the species
this all happened in this burst
following the American Revolution and in
the French Revolution and the
Declaration of the Rights of Man and so
forth
now of course my theological opponents
and debates that I do often point out
well wasn't it the Quakers and the
Mennonites who led this revolution it's
true they they were some of the earliest
to agitate for this a century before
that happened so their religious drive
to make this happen did nothing the big
champion is often portrayed William
Wilberforce it's true William
Wilberforce did agitate in British
Parliament to abolish the slave trade by
the way he was trying to abolish the
slave trade not slavery itself as an
institution just stop the trade for for
England and but also he was kind of
obsessed with moralizing about people's
behavior he was one of those we defined
people that are obsessed about that that
somewhere someone out the Puritans
someone someone out there is having fun
and we need to put a stop to this and so
he was he was on about all sorts of
things slavery was just one of his
causes but the main thing is that who
were his opponents in Parliament and in
culture it was all his fellow
religionists who were siding right and
left biblical passages in support of the
slave trade and slavery in any case if
you believe that morals come from God
and you believe that the creator of the
universe wrote a book that's supposed to
be the best book ever written about
morals how come he didn't get it right
about slavery how come there's nothing
in there something really
straightforward and simple like thou
shalt not enslaved thy fellow humans I
mean it's not hard you could have put it
in there so instead we get the
sort of twist the tourney spin-doctor
inna well they weren't really slaves
they were more like housekeepers okay
well and so and then torture this is a
which being broken on on this device and
then waterboarded sort of and stretched
and this the the abolition of judicial
torture happened again around that same
time late 18th early 19th century in
countries the rack was discontinued the
rack that so you're at the top your to
risk of there and at the bottom your two
ankles go and they stretch you apart
here are some from the jail and the
torture museum and the Hague which we
just visited when we were there and so
those those devices are or you strap
them around your hand or the the bottom
ones are for your thumb they clamp down
and your thumb and and as you exit the
museum I found they had this on display
so this is the goddess Justitia and so
note her accouterments she has a balance
scale for fair trials fair balance fair
and balanced she has a blindfold so
she's not biased against whoever's on
trial and then she has a sword to
enforce the law and so this is what
actually happened with the abolition of
torture and slavery the idea from
utilitarian philosophers like Jeremy
Bentham or the Enlightenment philosopher
Cesare Beccaria who the latter wrote a
best-selling book in 1764 an essay on
crimes and punishments in which he wrote
there ought to be a fixed proportion
between crimes and punishments so this
is the first to articulate the principle
of proportionality the punishment should
fit the crime so this was the first
attempt and this is why I use this
example to apply reason in science I
mean science and the broadest sense of
using reason and empiricism and and
logic and testing ideas in the real
world that instead of moralizing about
sinful behavior and then punishing
people for their Just Desserts torturing
them and locking them up and so on let's
see if we can reduce crime just to treat
crime as a problem to be solved rather
is a sin to be punished and this is
where it begins it begins in the
Enlightenment and and so you see again a
burst of the abolition of a capital
punishment and torture and capital
punishment the idea behind the
guillotine believe it or not was a bit
of progress that is instead of torturing
people with those devices the idea was
to eventually kill them but kill them
after maximal suffering and so these
devices the guillotine of course little
Sparky the electric chair which didn't
always work and the reason these were
abolished is because the idea was that
well maybe they're still suffering and
this is why lethal injection is still is
now again considered something when
controversial because it doesn't
apparently work very well although I
find this sort of weird you know how
they used that the last couple have been
botched you notice they used this word
botched which is kind of weird because
the guy died
it wasn't botched they killed him it
worked but but our intuitions are that
but he groaned any moan and it took two
hours and they had to keep giving
injections the whole point of an
execution now is that it's supposed to
be suffering free just make it as
quickly as possible
so anyway I just find this so weird that
these guys can't do this very
efficiently in the 21st century I mean
I've been a pet owner of my whole life a
dog dog owner and I've had to euthanize
some of my dogs you take him to the vet
it's a heartbreaking thing if they have
a blanket and he gives them a shot he
falls asleep he gives them a shot the
heart stops the whole thing takes like
three minutes just take these guys to
the vet
these guys know what they're doing again
don't don't don't don't take everything
I say seriously my prediction for the
well the death penalty's on death row in
America it's the we're the last of the
Western democracies to have the death
penalty I'm predicting by 2025 this will
be gone the only reason there was this
huge burst in the late 80s early 90s was
because of the crime wave in the 70s and
80s due in part to the illegal drug
trade where there's a when there's a no
free market for a product then you have
a black market where there's a black
market you have criminals and so forth
so once that was over the
and the number of death penalty a death
sentences given began to decline and
finally I also deal with animal rights
this is probably the next rights
revolution to come about after say the
same-sex marriage that whole thing will
be over oh by the way I'm pretty looking
that'll be over this year because the
Supreme Court's supposed to Supreme
Court's supposed to vote in June on a
particular case and if it goes the way
we think it'll go then then legally the
legal battle will be over the cultural
battle will take another five or ten
years and then same-sex marriage will be
exactly like interracial marriages today
what right no one even talks about this
anymore but that was a thing in the 60s
four percent of Americans supported
interracial marriage in 1959 four
percent now no one even talks about
anyway so that's where we're going by
the way I also predict mark my words
here since we're on tape that religions
will take credit for the same sex
marriage revolution they will they'll
say you know that Episcopalian minister
that was our guy you know okay well but
we have the surveys that I showed you
and so the animal rights movement really
began with again another Enlightenment
philosopher utilitarian Jeremy Bentham
we said the question is not can they
reason or can they talk but can they
suffer so our moral considerations have
changed shifted from again from this
idea of of sinful behavior that should
be punished to the survival and
flourishing or in the other direction
the suffering and death of sentient
beings and so I use sentient beings
rather than humans because there are
other sentient beings that can suffer
and so how far is the moral arc bent
well everyone today conservatives
included are more liberal than liberals
were in the 1950s you don't see signs
like this anymore you don't see pictures
like this a mom and her son watching a
mushroom cloud arising in the background
in Nevada in the 1950s you don't see
public executions like this anymore
grande fun let's all go down to the have
a picnic and watch somebody be hanged or
the KKK having fun at the at this
Kirkus or more relevantly well it's good
again as bad as these police shootings
have been it's good to remember it
wasn't even a century ago when this was
a thing just just look at the faces of
the people in this photograph they're
just like standing around like yeah it's
another Friday evening of entertainment
this is how bad it was compared to now
so as abysmal as as upsetting as it is
for these police shootings that we've
just witnessed it's again it's nothing
compared to what people used to do if
you want to I don't want to play this
because it takes too long but but but
Nina Simone's version of Billie
Holiday's strange fruit is a disturbing
song strange fruit you know hanging from
the trees and you know blood on the
leaves and brought on the roots and all
uh anyway so we've come a long ways and
but what about what about Isis what
about violent forms of religion they
they they beheaded people they burned
people alive okay so my talks in three
parts that I'm going to shift to talking
about what causes all this to happen by
using a current example like this and
then comparing it and reminding us that
we used to do things like this
Christians used to behead people and
burn them alive this is from a 12th
century French illuminated Bible it
shows two Jews kneeling about to be
beheaded by two Christian warriors there
with their swords with Jesus looking on
approvingly from above their crime was
they killed Jesus the Jews killed Jesus
okay this isn't this is a moronic idea
Jesus was Jewish so what and in any case
if Jesus had to die to save you for your
from your sins so that you can spend
eternity of you to heaven shouldn't you
be thanking whoever killed him because
that was part of the theological plan
that the whole thing was designed okay
this is just a bad idea that we have
abandoned so I it's burning witches this
is a particular
heretic in this particular case so I
call this the which theory of causality
that is if you think that women
cavorting with demons in the middle of
the night causes crop failures the
plague death accidents shipwrecks
childhood deaths and so on then you're
either insane or you live 500 years ago
when everybody believed this so what
happened with the witch theory of
causality we abandoned it we debunked
witches there are no witches there are
no demons it is demonstrably provable
that women can't fly around on
broomsticks laves are better off
enslaved than free this was one of the
big arguments in the in the 19th century
about why slavery was good oh they're
really better off we're not just saving
their souls for Christianity but they
eat better it's like it's like a country
club you know compared to Africa and so
on and they liked it there was actually
a disease called drape a tomainia drape
a tomainia was the tendency for slaves
to want to escape to freedom this was
considered a disease okay this is a bad
idea or that blacks are racially
inferior or that women are too weak
willed and too emotional to run
companies or countries or the gays want
to spread the gay lifestyle really this
is a thing that's I have conservative
friends one of my cycling friends makes
this art we're out riding talking about
current events and I think gays want to
spread the lifestyle and it's like
really you think like if you ran into a
gay and he started talking to you you
might go on the other team well not me
no no not me it's like right and by the
way when did you choose to be straight
what do you mean when did I choose to be
what anyway so this is again these are
just dumb ideas that people hold that we
can debunk or the next one that you know
us atheists are immoral or or were
communists or that animals don't feel
pain and they don't suffer these are the
kinds of things we're still debunking
there so in other words as Voltaire said
those who can make you believe
absurdities can make you commit
atrocities so my point here is that it's
it's not that these people are immoral
so much is that they're mistaken and
that correcting mistaken beliefs about
other people is the first step toward
expanding the moral sphere so now to
shift to sort of the longer arc here of
what I think happened this worldview
roughly called enlightenment humanism or
secular humanism of humanism began with
the Scientific Revolution and built from
there with this idea that I've been
emphasizing that instead of moralizing
about evil we should use science reason
to solve problems so what the scientific
revolutionaries discovered or what they
with the rule for the worldview they
constructed bacon Copernicus Kepler
Galileo Newton is that the universe is
governed by natural laws and principles
that you can understand sometimes even
right out with mathematical equations
and then apply the knowledge to change
the world so the moment that the the
scientific revolutionaries began this in
the physical sciences it quickly moved
into the biological sciences medicine
for example and then into what we would
call the social sciences so ever since
the Scientific Revolution in the
Enlightenment we've been applying the
methods of science to solving social and
moral problems if you look at the
background of all the founding fathers
the great enlightenment philosophers in
Europe and in England in the United
States you see most of them are
scientists now they didn't use that word
there was no word scientist until the
late 1800s they were natural
philosophers or they were naturalist or
they were philosophers or whatever but
they were doing empirical research they
wanted to know how does the world
actually work can we discover certain
principles a Montesquieu for example was
one of the great French enlightenment
philosophers who wrote a book called the
spirit of the laws l'esprit Tolui and it
the spirit by spirit he means the
environment the geography the
temperature the nature of the place that
the people live what kind of work that
they do what kind of society that they
have and how that affects what kind of
laws that they have how would you
structure a society to make it the most
efficient the most beneficial for the
most people based on their these
particular conditions he outlined all
this francois kanay was the physician to
the french king who started a movement
that became known as the French fizzy
Kratts and so he was a physician and
inspired by William Harvey and he sort
of made this metaphor between how blood
flows through a body in a circular
motion with how currency flows through
an economy and so the analogy was that
if you have a lot of blockages that
keeps blood flowing smoothly this causes
disease whatever and then if you have
too many governmental laws and
regulations in the economy it stops the
smooth flow of capital in the economy
and so this is where the word the phrase
lays a Fair comes from French word just
means leave alone just stop blocking all
the smooth flow of currency through an
economy this is sort of the basis of the
economic sciences and at culminating
with Adam Smith Adam Smith was a
professor of moral philosophy at
Edinboro but he is really constructing
the first scientific treatise on how an
economy works now most people think the
name of his book is The Wealth of
Nations that's not the title of his book
here's the title of this book an inquiry
into the nature and causes of the wealth
of nations
it's a scientific book it's a it's a
it's an empirical inquiry the book is
just chock-full of of empirical examples
of how things work because he wanted to
know the nature and the causes so we
could figure out how do we get more
nations wealthier it's a scientific work
Thomas Hobbes wrote this great book to
Leviathan it's a it's a big thick book
by the way it's ok to write big thick
books I discovered sorry he begins with
particles in motion atoms
he's an animist he begins with this idea
like Newton and Galileo and the and so
forth that there's particles in motions
and they're bouncing around and somehow
they impinge on our senses and then our
senses form and our brain simple ideas
and then complex ideas and you know he
spends chapter after chapter what we
would call association of psychology
where ideas come from and by the end 400
pages later he's got a civil society
here's how we should structure a society
now you wouldn't want to live in
particular society he ended up with
because he was supporting the king and
the English revolution but that's that's
aside when he considered himself had
even called himself the Galileo of civil
society he was inspired by Galileo and
William Harvey and so he was considered
himself a scientist so that's my point
that these people were doing rational
empirical hypothesis testing the kind of
kind of thing we would call science
today now there's one more benefit to
enlightenment humanism based on science
and reason and that is scientific
thinking is more abstract an abstract
reasoning expands the evolutionary
circle of sentiment so this is another
one of my hypothesis about a more recent
effect that's been discovered
that we're getting smarter this is
called the Flynn effect James Flynn is a
a New Zealand psychologist who
discovered by examining the data from IQ
test score companies that the companies
that make IQ tests that they they they
have to keep renormalized and so he went
back and looked at the data and he can
track it back almost a century that IQ
scores are going up about three points
every ten years but not the whole IQ
score if you look at the bottom line
there of information arithmetic and
vocabulary those are the kinds of things
you can actually practice and learn and
train and take those courses to get
better at and that doesn't have much of
effect the effects that have gotten
better are in the the abstract reasoning
portions the matrices and similarities
you remember matrices or things like
this so you're supposed to look at the
top row the middle row and then and then
figure out which one is missing so you
see there's a 2/3 1 a 1 2 3 a 3 1 so
it's obviously a 2 and then you know
there should be some blank ones there
because there's not in that third row so
it's number 5 so you could sort of
reason your way to doing that that this
is one of the simpler ones by the way
which is why I was able to figure it out
oh they get so complex and if you really
want to take the super hard ones that
are not even legal you go to Google
where they they give you these really
hard or similarities like what do dogs
and rabbits have in common so if you
said dogs use dogs to hunt rabbits
you're thinking more concretely if you
answered well both are mammals then
you're thinking like a scientist you're
classifying organisms by type which is
more abstract it's sort of an
abstraction so for the past century more
people are thinking abstractly than
concretely that's that's Flynn's
hypothesis I happen to agree with it and
for example he cites the
psychologist Alexander Luria who went to
test these Russian peasants and he asked
them for example what do crows and fish
have in common and one answer he got was
well absolutely nothing the fish swims
and a crow flies and Larry asked or are
they not both animals of course not a
fish is a fish and a crow is a bird so
the man could only think of objects is
is how we might use them not as abstract
objects part of a classification system
so there's flan and you know the IQ bell
curve they're shifting upward so flan
each of these it two more years in
school more technologies in society more
technical jobs more access to abstract
tasks as our economy has shifted from
agrarian and industrial to information
based in other words instead of
manipulating cows and plows and
machinery we're manipulating words and
numbers and symbols and this rewires the
brain in a more in a way that's more for
more abstract reasoning so thinking
scientifically requires reasoning
abstractly which is the foundation of
morality
so consider the mental rotation required
to implement the golden rule do unto
others as you would have them do unto
you this necessitates one to change
positions to become the other and then
to cognitively abstract what action X
would feel like as the receiver instead
of the doer is the victim instead of the
perpetrator this is really hard to do
for any of us but the idea is that the
better you are able to abstract it
rotate those figures figure out which
one goes where maybe the better you are
able able other things considered held
constant that able to do that like in
this New Yorker cartoon how would you
like it if the mouse did that to you
that cats going here okay so now I'm
going to do a big data dump on you this
is all from one section of my book just
to provide some peer evidence for this
for example people in societies with
higher education and measured levels of
intelligence they commit fewer violent
crimes they cooperate more in
experimental games like the prisoner's
dilemma they hold more classically
liberal attitudes and they're more
receptive to democracy so
let's go through some of these studies
the psychologist Michael Sargent for
example wrote a paper called less
thought more punishment so he found a
correlation between a high need for
cognition this is a cognitive
psychologists term for enjoying doing
those kinds of puzzles like those
matrices and low demand for retributive
justice even when such attitudes are
controlled for age sex race education
income political orientation so on okay
retributive justice is the kind of
justice that has been that religions
have given us for thousands of years
that is give the guys just desserts
you should just punish him he should be
made to suffer this is what's called
retributive justice the punishment
restorative justice is well but that
doesn't help the victim first of all we
should restore the damage that was done
and also the goal should not be to just
punish this guy for the hell of it
although it feels good we should try to
respects him why is he why is why are
criminals doing crime why are they doing
this let's look at this as a scientist
we look at it instead of as a moralist
would do it so sergeant's idea is that
people that enjoyed these kinds of
abstract reasoning are more likely to be
in favor of restorative justice than
retributive justice The Economist
Stephen Burks administered a thousand
trainee truck drivers the matrices IQ
tests like the ones I showed you and
then had them participate in a game of
prisoner's dilemma in which they could
either cooperate or defect with a game
partner you I'm sure you're all familiar
with prisoner's dilemma you and some
another person have an opportunity that
cooperate or defect and the reward
structure differs based on your first
move or your second moving and so on and
and it's better if both of you cooperate
you end up making more money or whatever
the particular reward is for doing this
and what he found was that these wannabe
truck drivers scored who scored high in
the ability to spatially rotate those
matrices figures were more likely to
cooperate on the first move of a
prisoner's dilemma game even after for
controlling for age race gender
schooling income and so on in other
words because the with the prisoner's
dilemma if it's a one-off one-shot deal
that you should just you should just
defect and try to screw the guy and get
you get you get your reward quickly but
but if you if you reason out well okay
but we're gonna play again and again and
again
then it's better if we both cooperate so
I'll start cooperating and think
thinking of that so that's a more
abstract reasoning sort of thing The
Economist Garrett Jones confirmed the
link in a meta-analysis of 36 prisoner
dilemma experiments conducted between
1959 and 2003 in colleges and
universities around the country finding
a positive correlation between a
school's mean SAT score and the
propensity of its students to respond
cooperatively so intelligence also
predicts classical liberal attitudes
such as the autonomy and well-being of
individuals an analysis of data from the
National longitude study of Adolescent
Health found that among 20,000 young
adults there was a positive correlation
between IQ and liberalism data from the
General Social Survey clarified the link
and noting that the correlation was
between intelligence and classical
liberalism of the Enlightenment kind in
which smarter people were less likely to
agree that the government should
redistribute income from the rich to the
poor but more likely to agree that the
government should help African Americans
to compensate for historical
discrimination the psychologist Ian
Deary confirmed this link in a paper
aptly titled bright children become
enlightened adults Drewry found a
positive correlation between the IQ of
British children at the age of 10 and
their endorsement of anti-racist
socially liberal Pro working women
attitudes at the age of 30
holding the usual intervening variables
constant so in other words the causal
arrow was from intelligence to moral
abstraction confirmed by the 20-year gap
between the measures by the way define
enlightenment the way I mean it the
philosophy emphasizing reason and
individualism rather than tradition
secularism in other words intelligence
also predicts economic attitudes most
notably such abstract concepts of how
free trade is a form of positive some
nonzero game that is counterintuitive to
our folk tribal folk economic intuitions
that most economic exchanges are
zero-sum and a fixed pie of wealth it's
just the way almost all of us think
naturally it's like if that guy gets
that much then I'm getting that much
less that's not how economists think
about economies but that's how
intuitively tribally and that's how
things used to be but not now
the economist Brian Kaplan cold data
from the General Social Survey and found
a correlation between intelligence and
openness to immigration of free trade
and a reluctance to endorse government
wake make Work Projects protectionist
policies and market interventionism
concrete thinking leads us to endorse
economic tribalism along with populist
and nationalist zero-sum attitudes
toward other tribes
whereas abstract reasoning leads us to
consider other tribal members as
potential trading partners to be
respected rather than potential enemies
to be conquered and slaved or killed in
other words like we could invade Canada
the longest undefended border in the
world and take the nickel with our
troops but it's a lot cheaper to just
buy it by the way I should point out I
like this this at the bottom right there
we want free markets not crony
capitalism the crony capitalists are
people that they claim they're in favor
of capitalism but they still want tribal
benefits they still want you know
special privileges that's not capitalism
this is an interesting idea that the
thinking about the economy is an
abstract concept the linguist Geoffrey
nunberg notes that in Bruce
Springsteen's lyric the river do you
know the song you know I got a word a
job working construction for the
Jonestown Company but lately there ain't
been much work on the account of the
economy number of notes that a century
ago they might have said on the account
of the Jews or the Negroes or the rich
peasants
so the economy has sort of been
inculcated into all our thinking it's a
causal variable it makes things happen
it's a thing that exists intelligence
predicts Democratic tendencies most
notably the rule of law psychologist
Reiner renderman ran correlational
studies on a number of data sets from
many different countries examining their
average scores on popular intelligence
tests and measures of academic
achievement from 1960 to 1972 and found
that IQ and academic achievement scores
predicted the level of prosperity
democracy and the rule of law found in
those countries in the subsequent period
1991 to 2003 controlling for the
intervening variables and then finally
and this data dump just recent studies
in the last two years have
that reading changes the way people
interact with other people and how
capable you are reading somebody else's
facial expression this is called mind
reading not the psychic type that we
debunk in skeptic but the ability for me
to look at you and your facial
expressions interact with you and figure
out what it is you're thinking based on
those cues that you get and certain
preliminary studies so far as half a
dozen or so that eye sight show that
people that read novels in particular
fiction seems to put you in the in the
mind of the character in the novel and
look at the world through them and that
makes you better able to read facial
expressions so these little tests they
do they show different facial
expressions you have to tell well that
this one's angry this one's sad this
one's depressed happy whatever and the
people that read a lot are better able
to do that they've done these fMRI
studies where somebody's you know
reading a passage out loud to them and
these little headphones inside the brain
scanner and and and you can see that the
person's brain that's getting scanned
the areas that are lighting up are the
same as the person that's doing the
reading who's in another scanner and so
it maybe literally transports you into
somebody else's head through the use of
words now there's some controversy about
those I should point out because they
people that do this call this high
literature sort of high culture
literature highbrow literature and then
they contrast it with like People
magazine or something but I have a
feeling there's a there shades of grey
in between there and there's a lot of
authors that aren't gonna be really
upset that they're in the one category
and not the other category and I'm not
sure what it is exactly that's going on
with that the quality of the language
the vocabulary of the sentence
structures are what or what or if it's
just the power of visual imagery okay
and then finally let's look at since
we're here at the long now foundation I
thought I would look at the future a
little bit so this is in the last
chapter of the book and so I start right
off with the problem that arthur c
clarke pointed out way WAY long time ago
if we learned one thing from history and
invention and discovery it is that in
the long run and after and often the
short run the most daring prophecies
seem laughably conservative and this
from the guy that came up with the idea
of the of the telecommunication
satellite still as Robert Browning
suggested a man's
should exceed his grasp or you know
what's a heaven for all right so now I'm
just gonna get just throw out some just
some crazy ideas that probably in a
century for now they'll seem super
conservative but so and so I called this
chapter proto Pia because I reject the
idea of utopias that is this
unattainable place where everyone lives
in perfect harmony forever every time
anybody has tried to implement one of
these it it leads to a big body count
it's a really bad idea there's no such
place instead in tribute to Kevin Kelly
who's here proto Pia his term that it's
progress in an incremental way where
every year it's better than the year
before
but not by very much just a micro
mountain so this is all I'm suggesting
let's try to get from here to there but
there is no there there we're just
trying to make things better tomorrow
than they are today
so instead of thinking of quantum leaps
from like 1950 jalopies to flying cars
just think of super smart cars just run
by computers just here every year the
next model slightly better than like my
new my new Ford Flex has my old one had
heated seats my new one has heated seats
and air conditioned seats oh my god Wow
okay I know that didn't sound like big
leap in moral progress but I live in
Southern California and enjoy in August
my ass is really happy about the
air-conditioned seats anyway that's all
I'm talking about just micro okay so
let's look at two areas politics and
economics okay so we're all used to the
nation-state and there's a historian
Quincy right noted in 15th century
Europe there are over 5,000 independent
political units by the early 17th
century these are coalesced into 500
political units and by 1800 they were
around 200 today there's around 50 so
we've been on this sort of downward
trend so some speculate that oh maybe
this will lead to a one-world government
I don't think so I think actually just
the opposite and the reason is is what I
call the fixing the pothole problem that
that some government in 10,000 miles
away doesn't care about the pothole
right out there so maybe in centuries
hence there'll be no more nation-states
their borders so porous economically and
politically
that the very concept will fall into
disuse and in their stead we'll see a
return of the city-state and so my wife
is from Germany we just were there we
drove for hours and hours across
different countries wit and we didn't
get stopped once no borders you can you
can drive for six days across America I
have to show your passport once you can
actually do that in Texas and still be
in Texas anyway but okay so but but the
so the world is moving in this direction
not in that knot of toward one-world
government but but poorest political
borders that are just easier to cross so
instead of power obsessed kings and
queens vainglorious dictators and
demagogues megalomaniacal fears and Dear
Leader's egocentric presidents and prime
ministers perhaps the most powerful
political person will be the mayor so I
think you had Benjamin barber here if I
loved his book if mayors ruled the world
so and he talked about cities collect
garbage and collect art rather than
collecting votes collecting allies they
put up buildings and run buses rather
than put in flags and running political
parties they secure the flow of water
rather than the flow of arms they foster
education and culture in the place of
national defense and patriotism as the
New York Mayor Fiorello LaGuardia said
there is no democratic or republican way
to fixing a sewer again solving problems
is the is the goal here and and this is
the direction we're going this is the
the percentage of the world's population
that lives in cities versus in rural
areas we're just right there at just
barely crossed just a few years ago from
more than 50% and now we're projected by
2050 to be at about 70% and by 2100 to
be over 80% of the world's population
will live in cities so cities is where
the action is so in other words only
number of political units coalesced and
solidified smaller and smaller but
instead of going all the way to one
world government bounce off the floor
and and back up into perhaps many
different city-states another book I'd
recommend the end of power in terms of
like the big units that have a lot of
power that control are in
ala T is declining powers spreading and
long-established big players are
increasingly being challenged by newer
and smaller ones and those who have
power are more constrained and than the
way that they can use it think of well I
found one study here how the weak win
wars so here's the data set showing from
1800 18-49 only eleven percent of the
weaker these are asymmetrical conflicts
where the weaker party wins only 11
percent 1850 to 1899 it almost doubled
to 20 percent from 1900 to 1949 up to 30
formless 35% and in the last half
century before our new century here it
passed over into the majority 55% what
am I talking about here we're talking
about like Vietnam for example you you
just doesn't work to just bomb somebody
into oblivion they end up winning the
war either for costs or bad public
relations declining power big
corporations that is this is the average
company lifespan on the S&P 500 index
has been going down and down from 60
years in in 1960 down to barely over a
decade projected in the next decade and
so another this is another decline of
power
okay so and instead then how these
cities look like so here's just some
more kind of speculation that may turn
out to be crazy or wrong or maybe it'll
be too conservative but there are books
there are people to think about these
things
the art of community and sital marketing
and alter by Spencer Heath and his
grandson Spencer Heath McAllen they they
just sort of got me thinking about we're
already doing these kinds of proprietary
communities shopping centers are
prepared that everything's owned
privately and and there's no problems
there's no conflicts there it's all
solved through proprietary technology
social technologies condominiums or
proprietary communities mobile home
parks retirement communities industrial
parks private colleges and universities
corporate campuses are proprietary
communities hotels if you think about a
hotel they have streets they have roads
the roads are either horizontal like
corridors like that or they're vertical
elevators they have town squares like in
the lobby they have stores and
restaurants a lot of them have music
centers you can go to you could take you
like if you go to Vegas you can you
could live in one of these Vegas casino
hotels and never leave and there's a lot
of people who do and they have various
forms of public transportation systems
that all works on a private proprietary
basis you don't you don't need
government to do this there's people
that have written about this Robert
knows it gets Harvard Anarchy state and
utopia forget utopia no such thing
anarchy we don't want anarchy you got to
have rules and Pete Leeson at George
Mason University he's just written a
book on this Anarchy unbound the word
anarchy is a bad word because people
think you know lawlessness no we need
laws we need rules and so forth but
there's ways to do that without a
national huge gigantic cumbersome
government okay my second subject proto
P and economics it's also called Star
Trek Star Trek economics you know where
you just go to the replicator and you
say you know Earl Grey hot and there it
is but maybe you want you know I want a
Tesla card there I don't know if you can
do that yet but this is the idea you
know money doesn't exist in the 24th
century because there's just so much
stuff okay this sounds insane at the
moment but there are people think about
this just follow the curves out here's
the curve for the last two thousand
years in terms of the amount of
prosperity and wealth that's available
in the world this is the projection okay
so that's six thousand two thousand
dollars the average per-capita GDP for
the entire world is six thousand dollars
a year so this is projected to double by
2032 almost twelve thousand though the
little dip is the financial meltdown
there in two thousand eight nine and ten
this from UC Berkeley economist Brad
DeLong so so this graph shows the
percentage of growth in real world GDP
per capita from for the last thousand
years
so everything happened pretty much in
the last two centuries and a lot more is
gonna happen in the next century so I
just did some quick calculations here so
this would be like getting the raise at
the end of the 21st century
but but in $2,000 that you had right now
so if you made so if the average
per-capita GDP is $6,000
it would then jump to $54,000 but not in
2,100 now it would be like having that
right now or if you make say a hundred
thousand dollars a year you'd all of a
sudden be making nine hundred thousand a
year now whatever the real figure will
be in a hundred years it you know
because of inflation and so on don't
worry about that it's just that's how
much more you'd make now you could buy
seven Tesla's nine tested and have left
over for some lattes at Starbucks
okay these are projections of course but
the idea is that they're not unrealistic
they're not crazy
based on just what's been happening
already okay I know what about poverty
all right I deal with income inequality
but too many slides too much data it's
real but but but instead of worrying
about how much the guys at the top were
making let's lift everybody at the
bottom up and so these are projections
for the end of poverty the Gates
Foundation is projecting by 2030 it'll
all be gone that may be optimistic but
still you can see here this is just
going oh sorry going all the way up to
2010 so the UN defines poverty is
regular poverty is making $2 50 cents a
day or less extreme poverty dollar 25 a
day or less
so the Gates Foundation and the UN is
also projecting by 2030 no one in the
world will be making adjusted for
inflation so on no one will be in
poverty anymore poverty will be over by
2030 maybe even earlier but that's that
would still be good okay so finally to
wrap it up here then we've made this
huge transition from what I call
civilization 1.0 of just primates living
in hunter-gatherer just little bands and
so on all the way to a you know a world
just imagine a world without any borders
no political borders no economic borders
you can travel you can trade you can do
anything you want with anybody you want
without any obstacles just imagine that
okay we're a long ways from there but
you know we're getting there so I'm
going to finish where I started with the
great dr. Martin Luther King jr. and
what that's a discussion questions that
so here dr. King is referring
to our moral nature that each of us is
two selves the great burden of life is
to always try to keep that higher self
in command and every time that a lower
self acts up and tells us to do wrong
let us allow that higher self to tell us
that we were made for the Stars created
for the everlasting born for eternity
well I'm not a Baptist preacher but a
scientist so that final sentence from
the book that we are in fact made from
the Stars our atoms were forged in the
interiors of ancient stars that enter
their lives and spectacular paroxysms of
supernova explosions that disperse those
atoms into space were they coalesced
into new solar systems with planets life
and sentient beings capable as such
sublime knowledge and moral wisdom we
are Stardust we are golden we are
billion year old Carbon morality is
something that carbon atoms can embody
given a billion years of evolution the
moral arc thank you
[Applause]
thank you so much thank you
okay oh boy Warren Kevin tells me the
first four questions are basically the
same question so I'll do all four and
then they'll have time to think about
Warren Bach says if we've debunked 5,000
year old idea that 500 year old idea
which is causing from death and crop
failure what do you think we will have
debunked as insanity five hundred years
now Rena Melnick says what moral issues
do you think we will be facing as this
society in about two hundred years no
Richard says what moral norms a hundred
years from now would be unrecognizable
to us today for example gay marriage is
someone from 1915 and William Ralph says
for this today's equivalent to 1950s
interracial marriage that is the thing
that only 4% of us support today but
will be unquestioned in the few decades
so yeah you know you're following this
arc here ya know we expect you to know
what's more than anybody else well first
of all III think well I heard the first
one religion is still a pretty pretty
powerful force in the world still the
majority of humans believe in God of
some kind most of them were monotheists
I think this is a problem I do and you
have only to look to the middle east to
see the empirical evidence of that
statement it's true that jews and
christians don't behead and burn people
anymore as i said because we'd a bunch
debunked that they went through the
Enlightenment there's one major world
religion that hasn't had an
Enlightenment yet they haven't even had
a Reformation yet so ayaan Hirsi Ali you
know one that wants to reform Islam
she's written a book about this I think
that's not even even that's not enough
you know when Christianity went for the
Reformation millions of people died you
know the body counts were high
Enlightenment's are better than
reformation x' because they don't
require
violence how long did that civil war
within Christianity go on well that
about a century and a half
thirty years war was the big one and
Treaty of Westphalia kind of put an end
to that but but by your hypothesis of
things getting better the civil war
that's going on within Islam between
Shia and Sunni would not take as long
this time hopefully hopefully well so
what's the solution I mean in the long
run would be better if people didn't
believe in Supernatural deities and
beings at all but I understand I'm still
in the minority for that but but let's
just start with like where I am wants to
start let's just have the moderate Imams
come out and say that's not in the book
okay you know that the real meaning of
the book is non-violence okay the book
doesn't really mean anything people
wrote it it's I mean it means what the
people wrote not that you know there's a
true meaning that because God wrote it
but still whatever it takes you know the
moderates to reform the extremists I'm
all in favor of it unfortunately
sometimes it takes troops and guns to
stop people from doing things like that
and I'm afraid that's where we're at at
the moment I'm discouraged about that
okay religion is kind of your
perspective on things there was a good
article in by John Burns in New York
Times last week where he was reflecting
on the he's retiring from being a
fantastic international journalist for
the New York Times at the age of 70 and
he was asked for the you know Sunday
thing to do a kind of a reflection piece
what did you learn from 30 years of
beating your brains out in all of the
tough places in the world and his
conclusion was that he has seen more
injustice and cruelty and immorality and
viciousness and weird rationalization
for doing what turned out to be vile
things and places that have strong
ideologies rather than doubts or an
endless negotiation about what's right
and so on he was not talking about
religious ideology he was talking about
any kind of agility ology sometimes
religious sometimes forms a political
some big story that you know the
communism was supposed to be a
scientific understanding of how society
should be organized they had their own
version of Leviathan yep
and so North Korea has an ideologies
which is you know more ironclad and
tougher on a society even then in the
worst of of Isis for example but you
don't talk about ideologies that are not
religious very much what you do so now
sure yep well because communism is not
the problem it used to be so I don't
have to spend much time on it it's
another bad idea debunked it was not a
scientific idea it was called scientific
socialism or whatever but that was a
thin patina over a deeper sort of
anti-enlightenment romanticism about
race and soil and and particular ideas
that you know of the class of people so
it's in a way it's it's the utilitarian
argument run to its extreme dangerous
form that that is that the good of the
group is more important than the good of
you the individual yours at your own
survival and flourishing so ferocious
nationalism fits in that area yeah
absolutely and and that idea has been on
the wane this is that book the decline
of power that idea that like national
pride and we should go to war because
it's great for the nation this is now
thought of as kind of a stupid idea
I mean who thinks like that well there's
a few in Texas and Republicans yeah but
I mean in a way we're you know I don't
mean to pick on one party but was
Republican well I understand it and and
but but even Roosevelt was totally in
favor of war this idea that it's it's
uplifting it's heroic his prize for
stopping the war between Russia and
Japan yeah that's right yeah
okay but but okay so back to the you
know they're not the Nazis were not a
scientific scientific based society it
was
then patina over this idea of race and
soil and a people a folk that was you
know okay so you know this you know the
thought experiment about the trolley
going down the tracks and it's gonna
kill the five workers and you're
standing there at the switch and you can
throw the switch and it trolley goes
down this other track and it'll kill one
worker if you don't know anything it
goes down the track kills the five
workers who mysteriously can't hear the
train coming or something and so do you
throw the switch do you kill the one to
save the five okay millions of people
have taken this test online almost
everybody says I would throw the switch
it's a utilitarian calculus I would kill
one to save five okay so but the problem
with that is that first of all no one
asked the one how he feels about this
and and the second of all things like
the Bill of Rights protect us from that
very problem that is it doesn't matter
how many people think I should die to
save how many people over here I still
have the right to live so that that's
why certain rights Trump utilitarian
arguments like like the rule of
democracy we don't allow that because of
that problem and so all these ideologies
you mentioned all of them are based on
this utilitarian all right the good of
the group
Trump's to go to the individual no it
doesn't it does not and and that's a
moral progress question from Damon what
is the biggest threat to the moral or
the biggest threat well you know the
immediate one is is religion Islam it's
the elephant in the room I'll just say
it one of these days I mean I think you
see a circular trend so when religion
goes away moral arch story is finished
well I said no because I still worry
about you know nationalism rising up the
whole idea of a nation I mean what is a
nation you know the whole Putin thing is
kind of brought this back up is if the
geography is that the language is that
the culture is that the beer they drink
you know what is it that we define a
group as and this is just an archaic
another bad idea you know where all the
members of the same species just forget
the boundaries the borders the language
the beer you know those are interesting
little side lights of places you go that
are fun like oh they got a orange bridge
let's go walk across it that's cool but
that
different from bladed today right which
we did today I'm glad I'm sitting but
but again that so that that kind of
group national whatever you want to call
it group ideology it against the
utilitarian argument run run amok it's
too much so that I worry about and then
back to the earlier question I think
animal rights is I think we're a long
ways from treating animals as sentient
beings but we're getting there I mean
it's a it's that's probably gonna be
decades maybe a century I mean the
percentages of vegans and vegetarians in
Europe and the United States it's still
single digits it's a long ways from even
being two digits do you have a position
personally in that do you eat meat do
you eat meat Oh Marxist do you eat meat
you eat farmed animals would you eat
dogs farm for food as they do in some
Asian say it's a work in progress
I had I had a kale salad and and carrot
soup today so that was it was a good
step and you're not taking me to a steak
house tonight afterwards there I use me
what can I say you know because the time
silent generation I'm dead soon sorry I
didn't mean to pick on you that way from
eating all that fat heart Kevin Kelly
yes can we have moral progress without
economic progress you made a big case at
the end is a big part of it I mean just
for just just to get people out of
poverty who cares what global warming is
gonna be in a thousand years if you
don't have anything to eat tomorrow I
know so we got to get everybody out of
that to care about the bigger moral
issues is a global warming a moral issue
well I think it is in terms of well in
the bigger picture it is the climate is
suffering we've got that just how we
live okay that you know if that is I the
idea of restricting poor people from
using fossil fuels for example I don't
think that's fair because that's the
quickest way out of poverty it's a shift
from burning cow pies in your Hut to
using coal-fired factories that are you
they give you electricity we got to get
these people out of poverty somehow if
you can do it through your small nuclear
you know units I'm all in favor of that
forget fossil fuels if we if we can do
it but I don't see a way to get them out
of there in the next five years ten
years okay but but I'm open to ideas you
know other solutions let me a stroll
through religion again for a minute
there's a book by Rodney stark a few
years ago I got turned on to you by
Garrett Gruner who may well be here I'll
call one and true God yeah amazing book
changed my mind about some stuff what
he's pointing out in there is that the
the most ferocious religions the ones
that are probably toughest in terms of
morality that you speak of are ones that
have a monotheistic situation one true
God which means all the others can
forget it they're not the true God
they usually have a book a Koran or a
Bible or something and there are
religions such as Buddhism many kinds of
Buddhism that are not particularly one
true God oriented and are not as
ferocious in terms of morality and maybe
the the kind of political national
ideology you talk about that you often
see things like president for life if
you go into a country and there you see
a photograph of the leader on the wall
in everybody's place of business
suggests there may be some kind of local
version of one fruit god going on yeah
yes it's a cult of personality yeah it's
tapping into certain ancient neural
pathways there that you know look up to
alpha males or whatever it's something
it's something like because we're a
hierarchical social primate species ok
so you've written about your brain on
religion yeah what are you talking about
here I'm talking about just this
glomming on to certain social structures
that a lot of people like that are
hierarchical in nature that are
predictable that are comfortable and
there's a you know there's a sizable
portion of the population that prefers
just by genetics just just by
temperament they prefer a worldview
that's stable predictable hierarchic
but every one of those who had called
Republicans yeah no sorry but look I was
a soldier once and I was in that and it
was a deeply socialist situation and you
know you have a boss and they had a boss
and Janek man is pretty strict and all
that stuff um it was very comforting and
gets a lot done when it wants to make
something difficult to happen have you
ever been in an organization like that
where you really you know have a place
and that's rapport well I'm not a member
of any organized political party I'm a
libertarian and there's a little bit
like herding cats
you know we okay in libertarian circles
that's really funny but but I've sort of
been disowned by libertarians because I
now think we should have some gun
control and climate change control and
things like that and and now no okay
well I go where the data goes rather
than with the politically partly saying
this is the whole idea of science as I
understand it is science it's organized
skepticism and it sounds like you are
organized enough about your own
skepticism that you're willing to change
your mind about say gun control even
though you're a libertarian yeah that's
right between is that part of morality
is having that open-mindedness to take a
different view on something okay yes
that's right I think one of the
contributions of the Enlightenment was
to say there are no final answers we
have to just work toward finding better
answers and it's a never-ending process
which is what democracy is in a way
democracy is like an experiment
jefferson referred to it as an
experiment like 27 times in is the
constitution and so on
and and because we don't know how to run
a country nobody does so we have to
continually retweet the variables called
elections and run it again for a few
years and see how it goes and to yet
there has to be adjustable constantly
because we don't know is that part of
what you like about mayors is that
they're they're all trying different
things and used to get is sort of burned
they watch each other yeah they in a
sense are as the body of mayors like the
you know the what is it the 60 cities
that have organized for climate change
the c43 called me out bigger which then
has been talked about
here that's partly like you say based on
potholes and sewer systems but it also
seems to be based on this they don't
have to pay attention to each other that
they get kind of rewarded for paying
attention to what each other we have
gavin newsom on the stage here and and
he said i keep a very close eye on
Seattle and Vancouver in Portland and we
want to beat them the competitive nature
of it it's great because that's what
science is science is very competitive
the reason we were reasonably confident
that global warming is real and
human-caused is not because there's a
consensus of scientists who say so
because it's like a democracy it's
because the scientists are so
competitive with each other that this by
the time we get to the finished product
we know it's already been tested and
competed and and so forth in this
marketplace of ideas that some young
scientists would debunk some other
scientists theory of whatever the ice
cores or the cloud you know models or
whatever that that that's that
competitiveness that gets us a little
bit of prototyping just a little bit
more closer to the truth that truth with
a capital T but just a little more
accuracy of our models so part of your
guiding economically part of your
guidance is never stop arguing yeah
that's right yeah yeah the argue arguing
is good this is what this is what the
whole enlightenment was about was you
know these scientists competing with
each other just the market for the
marketplace of ideas there are no final
answers this is the problem with
religion they think well that's the
answer no we don't know the answer t
gross asked what would it take to
achieve the equivalent of Moore's law
for moral progress a kind of impatient
so you've showed a pretty you know kind
of most of those things were going along
pretty flat and there was a band and
then they've been kind of flat since
it's not exactly a asymptotic curve no
don't why don't have some kotti curve
well I'd be nice but are you sure human
nature well maybe not because we should
again the problem of making huge leaps
is that if you make a mistake it could
be catastrophic say more about that well
again before we change a law you know
just change a whole legal system totally
and overnight because if you're wrong
then that could lead to a high body
count
it's just historically that's what
happens that's was that was the problem
with the French Revolution so there's
this great debate between Thomas Paine
and Edmund Burke about the American
Revolution versus the French Revolution
the American revolutionaries were fairly
incremental about it let's just not
let's not throw overthrow everything
let's just change the tax lawyer let's
just change this little thing here and
there and so forth and in the in the
Declaration of Independence it says
right you know right there that things
should we should not just throw things
over we should have really good reasons
for it and here's our 27 reasons and
here's little things we want to do
whereas the French revolutionaries just
went crazy and just started cutting
everybody's heads off and so on and
that's why it wasn't so so so I mean
there's certain institutions we we
shouldn't hang on to like slavery
torture death penalty things like that
but there's other institutions that you
know that that you know that are good
that we should keep the rule of law and
and so forth so so it's okay with you if
religion takes a time disappearing from
your well let's have much say in the
matter I'd like to have more say but I
think we're I think you know like my
atheist friends like Dawkins and
Hitchens and Harris and so forth and we
came out together you only do yes I know
I know it's it's like a club we have a
drinking club you know we talked about
well you know Wednesday 8:00 you know
when will we be the majority you know
we're a long ways from that but the
fastest growing religious group in
America are the nuns the people were one
out of five twenty percent twenty
percent it's thirty three percent of
Millennials born after 1981 again the
young people are gonna rock in Europe it
went from you know just in in in about
half a century went from the majority
position to the minority position in
many European countries religious
religious 'ti rates of religiosity so
that's encouraging here's a question I
don't understand that you might from Bob
Coppock says do you ever feel you're a
modern man stuck in a postmodern world
are you referring to People magazine
sound like a song or something I'm not
sure what's that post I think that we
post postmodern by now yeah I think we
are yeah that's also you know the
problem is is you know we're all stuck
in where we're stuck in a hundred years
from now who knows this probably be
laughably conservative I mean so my wife
and I were just doing my European book
tour so my first stop was Amsterdam and
so the pub my publicist sent along this
literature saying this provocative new
book that suggests gay marriage and pot
legalization and they're like
provocative right we've been doing this
for years it's with you Americans so you
know maybe in a century from now this
will just be whatever here's a question
from God God
would God like to stand up just so we
can see now listen I don't know Dawkins
that well okay anyway God's question is
is there an ultimate morality what does
society look like when it's at the
pinnacle of morality okay no there's no
ultimate reality there's no pinnacle
there's no there there
there's no utopia don't aim for that
just again just try to make tomorrow a
little bit better today by the criteria
of expanding the moral sphere to include
more members of our species and other
sentient beings into our moral
consideration and by by what I call the
survival and flourishing of sentient
beings just just try to do that tomorrow
better than today the prop the problem
of the moment you design try to design a
society that's infinite happiness for
everybody forever that then you then the
problem is is back to the the trolley
problem what about the one person that
says I object how evil is this guy for
stopping us from achieving infinite
happiness for everybody for eternity
then it's okay to kill him that's that's
always the problem
alright here's one for the atheist in
you this is not from God this is from
Andrew well God's right-hand man and
he's referring to Paul blooms 2009 work
he spells it Oh 2009 thank you shows
that atheists give less to charity give
less change to the homeless and give
less blood to their religious
counterparts I guess other atheists yes
well that was actually David Brooks's
book called who cares
maybe bloom anyway yeah I wrote about
this in Scientific American yeah it's
true I mean if you you select certain
criteria that religious people are
better at they're better at organizing
the troops like hey everybody Sunday
morning tomorrow let's all go down the
blood bank and give blood okay so we do
that you know so they're but they're
atheist groups that do this this Sunday
assembly that I spoke at Sunday they had
like the little packages for poor people
and so on
there's nothing that any religious group
could do that that a secular group can't
do and there's plenty that do
it's just that they still out numbers so
it's true they give more more blood or
more - but but but that certain criteria
but there's others that you know that we
do well it so but the other wait wait
what are easiest religion well here I'm
talking about secular atheist
governments in Europe like Holland for
example that has a tight social safety
net where everybody is taken care of
true and the religions there have
nothing to do we ran into this huge
church in The Hague this thing was
magnificent and it was all locked up and
on the door was this big poster with a
picture of a corporate banquet inside
with a phone number you can rent the
church for a corporate banquet this is
the future of religion
I'm telling you mark my words the
Vatican is gonna make a great art museum
it already is in our museum so in other
words that but this is a serious point
that that is why our Europeans less
religious than Americans it one answer
is that one of the things religions do
is take care of poor people if the
government does it if everybody has
health care and everybody's raised to a
certain minimal level of survival and
flourishing then you don't need religion
that's one answer well you could
probably test that in Utah that would be
interesting
Utah well that well you can although the
Mormon Fundamentalist still try to soak
the government by they consider the
government evil so if you get on welfare
you can damage something like that but
Mormons actually have a fairly extensive
tithing program and this includes like
capital gains and you know if you sell
property and so on you and so they do
they do take good care of each other so
you don't really they don't need well
anyway the bottom line is getting people
up out of poverty and taking care of
people if the government doesn't
religions you don't need religion to do
it so that that would be that's that's
one the the other answer is that America
where the government doesn't support
religion then they have to compete in
the marketplace and American religions
have gotten really good at telemarketing
and and making religions more exciting
in European countries that the
government supports
mm-hmm my wife had to quit Church
officially to get them to quit taking
money out of her paycheck every month
for the Catholic Church can you believe
that in Germany they take money they
withhold money from your paycheck and
give it to your religion whether you
want it they're not and you have to you
have to opt out they do it until you opt
out and she can go down and fill out
this form she wore her four horsemen
Dawkins Harris Hitchens t-shirt it was
correct if I want to support atheism
word I send money well in Germany in
Germany the humanists qualify as a
religion and they get money they get tax
money this is why Scientology tried to
become a religion in Germany but the
Germans have had some experience with
fringe groups in the past and they said
oh no no no no we know what you're up to
and you're not and so they got
disqualified they were not allowed to be
a religion in Germany we had Steven
Pinker talked here a while back on the
decline of violence and his amazing book
how do you feel these the work you've
been doing relates to the work he was
doing in this area he was focusing
mainly on violence but he drew a lot of
attention to basically cruelty and
injustice as on the same related
declining curve as violence yeah do you
see yourself in complete continuity with
yep his story yeah I'm just Steve's
books a great book better angels of our
nature if you haven't read it read and
then the sequel your book basically just
pushing out from there saying hey look
if we know that democracies are better
than autocracies by 27 different
measures then we ought to be doing
things to help people become democracies
to help people around the world that are
being oppressed and that had their civil
liberties suppressed and so on we ought
to do this well why aren't we to do it
well then you need some kind of a
foundation for you know breaking that is
a barrier that you know well science
can't tell us anything about what we
ought to do yes it can we've already
been doing this for two centuries we've
been doing this we've been saying look
we can discover certain things about the
social world in the economic world the
political world that are really true
democracies really are better than
autocracies absolutely look at North
Korea
versus South Korea you can see the
difference from space one is black and
dark and dead the other one is alive and
rich rich at night at night well that's
the best time to see the lights and in
South Koreans their per capita GDP is
about twenty thousand a year versus
North Koreans per capita GDP is about
thousand a year that's twenty fold
difference that's a huge raise in the
quality of your food and standard of
living democracies and and and countries
that are open to trade and so on are
just better off on every measure so once
you know that then should don't we have
a moral obligation to help people that
that want our help yes you can't just
force everybody in the world to be this
but you know we should help them that
they want help hey that's my spreading
democracy was part of the reason given
for invading Iraq well yes okay so some
ideas are better than others okay that
was probably more of an execute well in
Academy right yeah it was it was an
excuse that played well so anyway um
last question
when Pinker spoke came out one it was
not a huge seller for him unlike some of
his previous books like the language
instinct tiller a certain amount of
pushback from you know Elizabeth Colbert
The New Yorker spent three pages saying
violence is still happening pay no
attention to his book oh I imagine
you've had some pushback for reporting
on this good news apart from that both
you and Pinker drawing attention to a
trend of improvement on an area which we
all care about does being aware of the
trend change anything well I hope so or
not well that's the idea like any other
scientific trend we would mark like
global warming you know the moment you
say well okay here's the trend here's
the potential consequences we ought to
do something about it they're right
there we're going from the way something
is to what we ought to do yes wait wait
so what are we to do about the moral arc
it sounds like it's a given and all the
sit around and watch it happen no it's
not a given it's not inevitable now the
whole thing could could reverse of
course but very unlikely think about it
what are the chances that slavery would
be brought back as a legal institution
in Europe or America very unlikely no
there is a lot of someone in formal but
real slavery going on with more people
and with more economics turning around
more globalization and so on there's a
lot of people who are owned yes ok that
but that's a slightly different thing
than we've already won the legal battle
ok you can't legally own somebody that
battle is over now is we have to do and
it's illegal in every country in the
world you have to do is enforce it so
enforcing the law is different than
changing the law we've already done that
so or just imagine you know like any
country any state in the Union or in
Europe that would take the vote away
from women where's my wife likes to say
away from men what you know it's that
perspective thing again that's very
unlikely to happen not impossible but
you know the trends the further down the
road you go the harder it is to reverse
the trend it could happen
yes none of this is inevitable it came
about because we made it happen so now
we can't sit back and watch it we have
to we have to be vigilant active we have
to make it happen
so the the frame of mind shifts but
you're saying that the application the
enforcement is something that actually
takes awareness of this trend and
doubling down on carrying yeah
absolutely I mean once you see well look
look what happened from here to here
well what made it happen
well these six things okay we ought to
do more of that if we no reasonable
reasonably confident that it works and I
think the people that pushed back
against me and Pinker for example it's
really a disservice to the civil
libertarians that have been fighting for
the past century all the suffragettes to
dr. King and so on it's basically saying
they did nothing their efforts were were
meaningless things are as bad as they've
ever been
come on that's not fair to them yeah
they did a lot look what they've done
and that's why you got a show so you got
to show those pictures once in a while
like the you know the the lynchings by
the way one of the other things I found
doing this research I was amazed I
always think of lynchings you know
blacks in the south beam
Lynch Chinese Americans or Chinese were
lynched in California you know that in
the tens in 1892 1920s and so I whoa and
so again that that's the sort of thing
that's come to an end last lynching I
think was 50 to 90 50 to something like
that so it's been out over half a
century so that's progress come a long
way a long way to go thank you for
helping thank you thank you thank you so
much
[Applause]
Thank You Stuart that was great I really
appreciate that
[Music]
you